اخبار العالم بايجاز من غرفه اخبار
الجزيره اهلا بكم استمرارا لتصعيد
الاسرائيليه شرطه تحمي مئات المستوطنين في
مواصلتهم اقتحام باحات المسجد الاقصى
وتعزز وجودها العسكري في محيط الحرم
الابراهيمي بالخليل الرئاسه الفلسطينيه
تردد وحماس والجهات تقولان انما يجري حرب
على المقدسات لن تمر دون رد
اشتباكات بين الجيش السوداني والدعم
السريع في الخرطوم وشمال كردفان وجنوب
دارفور وفد الاليه الوطنيه للتحول
الديمقراطي يقول انه سلم البرهان خريطه
طريق تتضمن وقف الحرب وتشكيل حكومه
الطوارئ ووزير التنميه الاجتماعيه يصف
الوضع الانساني بالحرج جدا
التوتر المستمر في البلقان بريشتينات تجدد
بالتخطيط عسكريا لضم شمال كوسوفو صربيا
تقول انها اعادت قوتها على الحدود الى
مواقعها ووسط تهديدات اوروبيه بعقوبات على
الاتحاد يناقش اليوم التازم بين البلدين
بسبب ما اسماها ظروفا غير متوقعه الاتحاد
الاسيوي لكره القدم يعلن الغاء مباراه
سيباغان الايراني والاتحاد السعودي في
دوري ابطال اسيا ووسائل اعلام سعوديه تقول
ان لاعبي فريق اتحاد جده رفضوا النزول الى
ارضيه ملعب اصفغان اعتراضا على ممارسات
النادي الايراني بوضع صور وتماثيل بعيده
عن مجال الرياضه الى اللقاء